hoy nos trasladamos a uno de los países
más grandes del mundo
si tenemos en cuenta que no tiene salida
al mar estaríamos hablando del segundo
país más grande en estas condiciones
sólo por detrás de su vecino kazajistán
hoy en visual política hablamos de
mongol
pese a su gran extensión su población
apenas ronda los tres millones de
habitantes haciendo que este país tenga
la segunda menor densidad de población
de todo el mundo sólo por detrás de un
país como groenlandia
esta baja densidad puede explicar se
debido a su orografía sus vastos
desiertos y grandes montañas hacen que
estos terrenos sean muy difíciles de
trabajar y casi imposibles de
desarrollar casi la mitad de su
población se localiza en la capital en a
lomba thor y gran parte del resto sigue
siendo aún nómada
tal e como lo eran sus antepasados que
las tribus se pelean como buitres por el
cuerpo de secado de una marmota se lucha
por que los recursos naturales son
limitados la gran dimensión del país se
explica por su historia y es que
mongolia fue durante siglo y medio uno
de los imperios más temidos y además fue
fundado por el famoso gengis khan el
gran khan gengis khan en 1.270 se había
convertido ya en el imperio más grande
de la historia formado por territorios
contiguos con una extensión de más de 30
millones de kilómetros cuadrados más de
un quinto de la superficie terrestre de
la tierra sin embargo el imperio se
desquebrajó debido a la lucha entre los
descendientes de kan mi pueblo alimenta
la leyenda de que su gran líder volverá
un día para guiar la caballería hacia
la sangrienta victoria
en 2017 lo que da de mongolia falso
ruido por el pre sensor de la sina
actual la dinastía qing a principio de
siglo 20 con su independencia parte de
mongolia permaneció como una de las
regiones autónomas de china mongolia
anterior y en la actualidad china aloja
más personas de etnia mongola que la
propia mongolia por otra parte poco
después de su independencia rusia hizo
de mongolia un estado satélite de la
extinta unión soviética de hecho hasta
que ésta se extinguiera no hubo atisbo
de democracia alguna en un gol
pese a su pasado comunista mongolia no
ha dudado en tratar de abrazar el
comercio y hacer casas gigantes
capitalistas como eeuu
hay que decir que mongolia mando tropas
tanto de irak como afganistán y este
hecho estoy agradecido por siendo el
primer ejercicio de eeuu de la historia
que licitará este país
wing station en mongolia a pesar de su
glorioso pasado
mongolia hoy no está pasando por el
mejor momento xubi per cápita ronda los
4.000 dólares por habitante y en 2005
uno de cada cinco habitantes vivía con
menos de 1.25 dólares al día
su principal en una exportadora es la
minería y supone el 80 por ciento sus
exportaciones
mongolia que es un país inmensamente
rico en minerales
la riqueza subterránea del país llegaron
a atraer a inversores de todo el mundo
trayendo hace pocos años una ola de
prosperidad a la tierra de gengis khan a
su capital ulan bator crecieron unos
edificios de oficinas y boutiques de
lujo sin embargo esa por una minera
acabó por explotar y es que las
frutillas vacías y los proyectos en
terminar asolan hoy la ciudad de ulán
bator
en su mejor momento en 2011 su economía
crecía un 17 3% casi 8 veces más rápido
de lo que lo hacía el año pasado está
caída debida fundamentalmente a la
recesión china ya que la siguiente 9%
las exportaciones totales de mongolia
tienen como destino este país la
recesión china ha afectado al mercado
global de commodities y esta caída de
los precios de materias primas ha
acentuado además las consecuencias para
mejor
el no tener conexiones marítimas hace
que el enviar mercancías a otros países
tenga unos costes elevadísimos y esto le
hace de facto dependiente a china sin
embargo no son todos sombras mongolia
mira con optimismo el futuro desde el
pasado diciembre gracias a un nombre oyu
tolgoi
un emplazamiento minero compuesto
principalmente por oro y cobre
y es que tras años de negociaciones con
la empresa de riotinto sobre qué
porcentaje de los beneficios debía
quedarse el gobierno mongol se ha
llegado a un acuerdo por el que se
desarrollará una inversión de 4.400
millones de dólares
por otra parte hay que decir que la
inversión en otras minas está totalmente
paralizada no sólo por la extracción de
la industria sino porque tras algunas
exportaciones por parte del gobierno la
confianza en los inversores no abunda
precisamente por ello el gobierno ha
decidido abrir otros caminos e intentar
incentivar otros sectores como el
primario o el turismo que permitan abrir
nuevas vías de crecimiento y superar la
dependencia a los minerales sin embargo
no deja de ser sorprendente que desde
enero de este año por ejemplo los
españoles necesitemos un visado para
visitar el país quién pone trabas a lo
que es saber crecer
espero que haya gustado el vídeo sitges
para el comentario no ve sin hacerlo y
también os recordamos como siempre que
podéis suscribiros para seguir al tanto
de nuestros vídeos un saludo y hasta la
próxima
sí sí sí